Speaker 1: Let's talk to people in the audience,
people in the audience.
We do this via Discord David Pakman Gqom slash
discord and let's see who's who who wants
to chat today.
Let's start today with Erin from Los Angeles,
California.
Aaron, you are on the air.
Speaker 3: And David, I just wanted to ask
you real quick, because I know that you've
spoken this on this a bit, but what's your
opinion on, let's say, a revolving door or
an open door order policy?
Because I've been reading a lot and I like
actually, although I'm not really a big fan
of Reagan, one of the few things I did enjoy
I didn't like about him, about his policies
were his immigration policies, such as like
the Bracero program and different programs
such as like granting amnesty to the undocumented
immigrants.
I was just wondering, what's your take on
immigration?
Speaker 1: Well, when you say revolving door
or open door, would you mean just anybody
can come in and out work?
No screening whatsoever.
What do you mean specifically?
Speaker 3: Yeah.
Well, like or, you know, at least alleviating
it for seasonal workers to be able to come
in during the agricultural season when it's
busy and then allowing them to return any
time, usually during the off season to go
back home?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I a lot of those things I'm
very much in favor of.
I do think there need to be some immigration
controls.
I am not for an open border.
I am.
I am not for this sort of fully libertarian
libertarian idea of total free movement of
labor and people.
I just practically speaking, I don't think
that that would work, but we've got to give
permanent status to DOCA recipients.
No one guest worker program.
Absolutely.
People, often when they say, shut this down,
shut that down, they don't understand not
only the degree to which industries are dependent
on workers from other countries, sometimes
undocumented, but also why some of the things
that they have are far cheaper as a result
of that labor.
And it's very hypocritical when you hear people
who want the cheap stuff.
If stuff gets more expensive, they would attack
whoever the president is.
But they also want that very same president
to quote Keep people out incoherent doesn't
make sense, and I'm for a whole bunch of the
things you're proposing, not open borders,
but for a lot of the things you're talking
about.
Yes.
Speaker 3: OK.
In terms of border security, though, how would
that work?
From my understanding, our current state of
border security is not only notoriously corrupt,
but it's also just like not working.
I mean, people are still able to like it's
mostly there to be able to prevent.
I guess, like drug traffickers are coming
in, but they're still managing to come in
at a rate that benefits their type of business
and industry.
So I was just wondering, like in terms of
border security, how should we reframe that?
So it's not just like a black hole that we're
just spending a lot of the taxpayer money
on.
Speaker 1: Well, two things.
We are disproportionately focused on people
just physically crossing the border rather
than people flying in and just staying here
or coming in with a visa and staying.
So one of the first things you have to think
about is you can disincentivize people from
doing the illegal crossings by making it less
necessary to do that.
And so a lot of the programs you're talking
about guest worker programs, et cetera, they
they remove a lot of the need to come in the
way that you're talking about.
So we just need to be thinking about it.
You're completely right that if you just change
one thing, it doesn't change the entire dynamic.
We need to be thinking much bigger.
Thank you, David.
Appreciate the call.
Thank you so much.
There's Aaron from Los Angeles